hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm gerry
there's some big news out there there is
Drew Goddard wasn't talks for a sony f
sony spider-man films i forgot which one
but then they were like oh now with
sonia marble teaming up jus guard is
probably out of the picture now you know
let's forget about drew everybody drew
doesn't exist anymore laughs i can i
drove everybody fetch me my chin on Tom
drew goddard though is announced that he
will be taking over spider-man is it
official it's official cuz like I read
about this like a day like yesterday but
I only knew it as like this is very
likely to happen I like this news a lot
and he's co-writing it too oh that's
good see see I love this guy I mean like
have you seen like Buffy and stuff oh
yeah he's written some great book and
Angel and Angel David bore oh ha with
have is my ass that's a shame David
Boreanaz I like my version at this point
the plot is unknown according to IMDb as
spider-man reboot that is untitled
currently at the moment it'll be called
the something spider-man with this
information I can conclude that this is
probably going to be a successful film
maybe well drew goddard is perfect wait
he's not that reputable to earth oh no
no no this is a choices that inspires a
little bit of confidence for me because
like Drew Goddard was like attached to
daredevil for a while and then he left
like they like there were some problems
with him in marble and the fact that
he's now in the mix for this one maybe
they're getting a little more confident
about their creatives now that like
guardians of the galaxy was so
successful okay but here's the
interesting thing he is in
pre-production stages for the Sinister
Six which is a DC film I thought they
didn't ain't ad I mean I don't know
because it still says an IV be that he's
in pre-production for sinister six but i
thought i read somewhere in that sort of
sequence of articles that because of
this he would not be doing sinister six
but i don't know if that's true enough
okay yeah cuz that would be kind of
crazy and trippy if a guy were to do a
DC movie than a marble phone yeah
because they sort of piggybacked on the
idea of like first he was supposed to do
daredevil didn't supposed to do sinister
six i'm now spider me I think Marvel
probably
a big part in choosing Drew Goddard was
they seem like they would be the ones to
do it you know well they've been
developing with him before them cuz that
was that daredevil he smoked to do a
daredevil series and then I didn't go so
well because Drew Goddard is only he's
technically we've only seen one film
he's done to was the second Cloverfield
while he wrote clover oh no I know he's
written more than he has direct and he
has direct you know there was cabin in
the woods which was really cool because
he knew how to take a similar theme and
take home you twist on India in some
ways it's so left field but you're like
they kind of fits that yeah well and I
mean you know coming off of things like
that and things like Buffy and just
really like you know he's sort of in
that just weighs a circled people and so
to write a spider-man movie like it he
seems like a really good choice because
so much of buffy and so much of Kevin
the woods is in that snappy witty banter
and stuff like that not dialogue not
just that he's someone who understands
character in an action story yeah
exactly like that's a rare thing to find
that would be great so that we can get a
well-written Peter Parker and a will or
the spider-man I think he's totally a
guy for that yeah cuz even in
Cloverfield the key to cloverfield
working was to make it seem like you're
just hanging out real people at first
and their interaction is pretty funny at
first so that's I mean you know sort of
being life two characters and the whole
goal of cloverfield was to try to make
it look realistic and he succeeded in
the writing of that and but AJ Miller
was the cameraman TJ Miller is hilarious
I love DJ really so on and so the
writing of it had to be authentic and he
did a great job hey as movies like cabin
in the woods which is a totally
different kind of genre you know it's
like some I go the book over but they're
different for sure not over like I feel
like meta [ __ ] like has to have its own
video store shelf but it's a different
style of writing just piggybacking off
that this guy who like clearly
understands the inner workings of genres
yeah exactly those were like he could
make a superhero movie that also sort of
pokes at the conventions of that genre
and he worked on lost a lot yeah and any
guy anyone who's on the writing staff of
lost is pretty [ __ ] mysterious that
everyone loves David little off yeah
he's the other thing we worked on lost
and lost
about he is very inventive well up until
the last time I see how are they he's
worked at JJ Abrams quite a few times
yeah you worked on alias alias is an
action show and that had to have humor
in the characters that's time he he
brings out a certain personality in the
characters yeah and I feel like he can
really capture Spidey's personality yeah
I know totally because it looks like i
said i think he'll be able to understand
the the sort of nuances of the character
enough for Peter and then have the
motivation and the form for just the
really snappy like one-liners and stuff
if it is Peter Parker though if it is
Peter for ya but whatever whoever it is
he I'm just gonna come up with reasons
to why I think you'll do a great job
yeah because it's him you know he knows
what he's doing he was also one of the
people who worked on world war z he
didn't yeah he didn't have like rewrite
the third actors in there I think he was
like the 47 3 right ok I'm happy about
I'm like legit no because it's taking
spider-man into the right hands yeah
this vitamin is one of my favorite
superheroes Lee you know it's like I
know I'm always the guy on these things
were like I'm kind of tired of big love
action movies but like spider-man always
gets me excited and this is good news
yeah I just I wish spider I wish Iowa's
spider-man did you ever like really
dream when you were younger they you
like how often did you do this [ __ ] a
lot I wish I would daydream for hours
just pretending I'm spider-man I
couldn't afford the web-shooter toy
growing up haha none of us had jobs back
but anyway guys thanks for tuning in for
today's news broadcast if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects and jerry has a show where
he does movie reviews in his vehicle I'm
not gonna make a masturbation joke got
your back BAM oh that's your penis as a
shotgun oh yeah take a mess right now
you were masturbating your penis as a
shot when you cocked it and you know it
you have a metal penis shoots bullets
it's not tattoo oh there man oh and you
can follow us on Instagram and Twitter
because we're that [ __ ] cool now
are you want to feel connected with you
so if you follow us there will feel like
when we're connected with you yeah we
can oh we can say hey hashtag hi yeah I
know that